[Music]
foreign
flooding on roads and roadsides is
common in heavy rain events especially
on our rural roads across the district
we have more than 1500 kilometers of
Roads so during a major weather event we
make sure to focus on our busiest
arterial roads first
our roading team constantly check the
network for any issues and put signage
in place where it's most needed
roads and Fords will be closed where
necessary
as a driver you can do a lot to help
always drive to the conditions and
assume flood water is deeper than it
looks
don't rely just on cones and signs to
warn you in major weather events make
sure you drive to the conditions there
may be potholes hazardous debris or
unstable Road surfaces beneath the water
if you must enter flood water Drive
slowly so you do not cause waves which
can damage neighboring properties
change rapidly during heavy rainfall and
there's always the chance that you're
the first motorist to encounter a hazard
if you are concerned about driving
during Heavy Rain or through flood water
just don't
Council has roving crews out in the
event of a major weather event
but we can't be everywhere at all times
so please let us know if you see
something on the roads
hello